la révolution industrielle plus de
platines plus d'ordinateurs centraux qui change
tout c'est plutôt cool je suppose que
ma chérie tout c'est posté sur comment
tu as pu ne pas me parler de cette fille je
travaillais juste dessus pour moi une joie
exactement pour toi pour toi c'est  c'est
ce que vous vouliez c'est avec votre instinct votre
instinct avertissant votre grand de ce qu'un
cerveau voulait quelque chose qui n'existait pas
alors vous l'avez simplement voulu pour qu'il existe
comment appelez-vous le système que
la suite d'opération a opéré dire ce que j'ai
choisi ouais juste un vrai-  affichage de l'
heure de l'opération en cours vous pouvez voir sur quoi
vous travaillez pendant que vous travaillez
d'accord c'est la liberté c'est la liberté
de créer et de faire pour construire et l'
artiste est individuel vous réagissez de manière excessive
même si vous développiez cela pour
des monstres comme nous et je doute que vous soyez
personne ne veut acheter un ordinateur
personne comment quelqu'un a-t-il su ce qu'il
voulait s'il ne l'a même jamais vu